[Music]
today i'm going to
show you how guided biofilm therapy or
gbt
works when we professionally clean a
patient's mouth from start to finish
my job as a dental hygienist is to
detect and treat but most importantly
prevents
periodontal disease biofilms are highly
organized
microscopic communities of bacteria but
it's responsible for bleeding gums for
bad breath
for some dental infections for some of
the unsightly deposits that we see
on our teeth and and of course it's
linked to some more
serious systemic diseases as well
so here we can see plaque and calculus
deposits but
but more concerning is the colour of the
gums which are red
and and they're also puffy and swollen
that would lead us to believe
either gingivitis or even periodontal
disease could be present here
one of the problems with biofilm is that
you can't see it
and you can't feel it so i use a die
called
biofilm disclosure which is an organic
coloured
dye
so when the dyes apply to the teeth
which have biofilm on them
it changes the color of the biofilm and
it's a really clever two-tone dye
so it means that it stains early bio
film which is less than three days old
pink
and it stains mature biofilm which is
more than three days old blue
the patient is shown in the mirror the
stained biofilm
biofilms are microscopic whereas the
plaque
is a biofilm that's matured and it's
large enough to be seen
with the naked eye ideally what we want
is to disrupt dental biofilm before it
has the chance to mature
into plaque
so this is where we start the the
cleaning process
and it is completely different to the
old-fashioned methods of
of curettage and hand scaling so here
i'm using a tool called airflowmax which
acts like a warm
jet wash for inside the mouth and it
uses a combination of warm water and
tiny soluble and antimicrobial
powder airflow max will remove 100
of the biofilm from the teeth and all of
the surrounding tissues
including underneath the gums where it's
dark and warm and the biofilm really
likes to hide
i'm also using the airflow max not just
to take the biofilm away but it takes
the stains away
as well so the mouth looks and feels
super clean afterwards
it's very comfortable for the patient
it's gentle
it's efficient it's very safe with no
abrasion
or damage to the tooth surface at all
after we've disrupted all of the biofilm
and we've removed all of the stains
uh pies on no pain is um
is used at this stage
and it uses ultrasonic vibrations to
remove
any remaining hard calculus it shaves
the calculus off very gently
so it's very different to the
old-fashioned methods of scraping the
teeth which would take calculus away
but would also scratch the tooth surface
[Music]
stage seven of the gbt process
um is is our quality control stage
really so
here i would spend a few moments
checking around the whole mouth
to ensure that all the deposits have
been removed and all the bio films
being disrupted um so at this stage i
would hand the mirror back to my
patients so they can see the before and
after results of their guided biofilm
therapy treatment
i usually ask my patients to run their
tongue over the teeth at this stage to
feel
how silky smooth they are and now that
the biofilm
and calculus is gone and learning good
oral hygiene habits
um is like learning to swim you have to
be shown and
so after dental hygiene is to teach you
how to clean your teeth properly
spend the most time and concentrate the
most efforts on the areas that you can't
see
that's where you'll find the most
biofilm so in between the back teeth
underneath the gum line around the base
of restorations
oh i love my job i love it so much
because i get to put smiles on people's
faces every single day
what other job in the world gets to do
[Music]
that
[Music]
you